the jurogan experience
you know i've gotten a a bunch of
messages since that film came out from
other
olympic athletes and um it's been either
a mix of like hey man i'm
thank you so much or it's just like not
mad at me
just like what the [ __ ] and
and then you know like like i was
actually like
invited um it was the uh
uh the bobsled team uh that when they
actually disqualified the russian
bobsled team
and uh uh the u.s bobsled team was then
gonna get the
third place medal they like invited me
to the ceremony
i didn't go but you know it was uh
crazy jordan said that
the i guess in 2020 and 2024
the russians can't fly a flag
like they they cannot they can't be
represented
like they have to be individual athletes
from russia at
at the olympics in 2020 and uh tokyo
it's 2021 now
yeah and then 2024 those olympics you
can't
have a russian flag like you literally
can't because of
what happened that you exposed in your
documentary
well that's that's true however
if you if you follow the the story post
icarus with rachankov
is russia was supposed to turn over this
lims data which was this
laboratory information management system
data
in order to be reinstated into into
world sport
that was part of the water requirements
and
they never basically
turned it over so water basically had to
go after them go after them go after
them
they reinstate them without turning over
the data then they turn over the data
this is now
december of 2019
or january it was not that long ago
about a year ago and when they turn over
the data
they had literally manipulated all the
data
and they had already got a copy of it
from rechenkov and another guy in the
lab
and they literally put notes into this
lims data
basically trying to frame rachenkov for
like money laundering and taking
bribes and all this [ __ ] but wada knew
that this wasn't legitimate because they
had the real databases
already so they go and they say okay now
russia's banned for another
four years right wow
and in the meantime russia is putting
out in the media that rechenkov has
tried to commit suicide
because of like the exposure that he was
apparently you know
taking bribes for money which he wasn't
russia denies it again and then it goes
to the court of arbitration
for sport this is literally just like a
couple months ago
so they were supposed to be facing
another four-year
total ban like that's what watta was
recommending like
the entire federation is gone and the
court of arbitration for sport which is
corrupt as hell basically knocks it down
to
two years instead of four years and then
basically does
what they did in the 2018 olympics which
is okay any russian athlete who hasn't
tested positive
can compete but they can't compete under
their country's flag
but if you saw icarus how would you know
whether or not they were positive or not
because they were
swapping out the urine they were
breaking into the bottles
so it's uh it's like yeah they're
kind of banned and at the same time
they're all gonna be there
and this was looked at it like a huge
win for russia
in the meantime brechankov literally
sits
in isolation in hiding under protection
um but the guy just got asylum so
you gotta tell him here right he got
asylum you don't have to wear the
headphones you don't want are they
uncomfortable
no they just kind of were like echoing a
lot if there's a way to maybe take down
the reverb on them or something i
like them echoing really do you hear
echo
echo there's a volume control is that
better yeah i think that's better
um so rachenkov has got asylum here in
america
yeah so he's got asylum here in america
and that story is crazy too so
you know uh in icarus you see this scene
where basically like
i see him off at the airport
and that was july of 2016.
so we keep you know making the film the
film comes out
august 2017 and then five months later
essentially because of the film the ioc
and the reasoned decision
comes forward and bans russia
and they cite icarus as one of their
their main reasons for doing that
in the meantime rachenkov is literally
trying to get
political asylum and on the day
of his asylum hearing this was now
a year and a half two years ago
i need to get with his lawyers to get
the exact date
russia files drug trafficking
charges against him in russia on the
actual day that he's supposed to go in
for his
asylum hearing so what this means is
that russia
had a mole within the u.s
immigration system knowing that
this was the day that prachanka was
supposed to get his as his asylum
and under international law anybody
who's been
charged with drug trafficking right
is basically immediately ineligible for
asylum so there's like a couple of like
you know things that you can be charged
for that basically
makes it you can't get asylum so they
charge him with drug trafficking
and the court then gets kicked out and
it takes him another year and a half
two years to get his asylum and he
finally just got his asylum like
four four months ago something like that
wow
crazy and so but he's still in hiding
right because he's got to worry about
being assassinated
oh yeah i mean he's he's still in hiding
i mean i've
i've been able to keep in touch with the
guy here and there through like
basically through the lawyers and then
they'll arrange through the security
and then we'll you know find an
encrypted way to like have a
conversation and and
um last time i spoke to him was about
two months ago and you know the
conversation always goes like
hey gregory how are you and he goes uh
i'm alive
and i could go uh that that's great
you know and he goes i'm like so how are
you doing he's like brian bryan
i have to tell you he's like you know
you saved my life
and uh uh i mean it's
it's it's heavy it's really heavy i mean
we've
we've tried for three years now to try
to get him a dog
because you know he loves dogs and he
lives by himself and
you know he really doesn't have
communication with the outside world
um my understanding is that he'll go out
you know for like an hour a day for a
walk with like
protection around him um i don't know
where he lives i don't i don't have his
phone number
but his security you know doesn't want
to have a dog
because if he has a dog that means he
has to you know go outside and he's got
to walk the dog
he's not really able to communicate with
his family
hasn't seen his family for you know four
years now
his wife and his kids are back in russia
so i mean this has been a this has been
a crazy cost
for for blowing the whistle didn't they
take his
wife and his children didn't didn't they
take their fam their family home away
well after he uh after he got here and
then all this started to unfold
um what i was told is that they
basically
like froze the assets um of the family
he had a
adacha which is like a summer home
and apparently they uh they seized that
and they seized bank accounts
um and they brought in the family to
interrogate them and they
uh they took their their passports um
from what i've heard
um is that
his kids have their passports back
and the wife does too but
you know you can make the logical
conclusion that
they're hoping that they travel because
if they
then could travel and they then go and
see gregory right they're going to be
able to find them
but you know to my knowledge
the family has been pretty much left
alone it was
it was bad for a little bit um but over
the last few years
um i've heard that you know that that
they're okay
and you know none of the none of the
family wants to
wants to to come because
even if they do then that means that
their lives are now
in isolation in hiding so
for them to come and basically you know
visit gregory or to come and
and move you know to be with him because
he could technically get his wife here
now that he has asylum but then
her life is going to be in isolation
and she's got family back in russia so
it's it's uh
it's complicated
and this goes on for the rest of his
life well i mean arguably for the rest
of his life
i mean when you look at you know uh
michael scherwitz of the
of the new york times did a story i
don't remember it's probably about a
year ago and he was
looking at all these kind of like um
murders that that were
[Music]
tied to putin and russia and one of the
stories that he came out with
um was basically this guy who was living
in the ukraine
he was working for the gas company right
and
he uh i can't remember if he
it was an attempted murder or no the guy
gets killed
and they catch the guy the assassin who
goes to kill him
and they pulled him up on trial and when
they catch this assassin apparently he's
got a
a piece of paper on him it's got a a
list of names right
of like basically like you know like uh
kill names
and this guy who they arrest and i know
i'm botching the story a little bit and
you can go back it was uh
uh was in you know part of the new york
times daily
and um and this guy that they go and
arrest um basically goes
yes i i've been hired i don't know why
but you know my job is basically to
to kill these people so they start going
through the list
and none of these people are really
known it turns out that the guy that he
had been
hired to kill into ukraine who was now
living like
a normal life in the ukraine he had
apparently helped
broker weapons deal to
the chechens right and
this was like whatever 15 years ago
and here this guy's living this quiet
life in the ukraine working for the
power company
and 12 years later they come and get
them i mean you look at the case of uh
scurple
you know the guy that they poisoned with
novichok a few years in salisbury
that was another case where you know the
guy had that was in england right yeah
that was in england the guy had been
you know out of sight out of mind for uh
for for 15 years um you look at even the
poisoning of alexander luthernanko in
2006
well at the time that they actually
poisoned lothanenko with with
polonium he had already been living in
london
for like seven or eight years he had he
had fled
to the uk that long ago so the whole
piece that
the michael shorts had wrote uh and put
forward in the new york times was
essentially that you know they don't
forget
and there's just and there's just
you know a list and when they feel that
that they can strike
uh they do catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience